[Music]
welcome to the jungle
this is xqc
piece of [ __ ] for your sake
second second sex sex so he was once one
of the overwatch league's best tank
players think that if he count carries
on performing like this he could be a
top three top four tank in the league
[Music]
he's a product of the Internet age a kid
who became famous online we won't do any
small dress and then all at once he was
thrust into a professional world
a clean-cut franchise professional
league where he had to be on his best
behavior
lock away his toxic side and put on a
show for the fans but that just wasn't
meant to be shut your [ __ ] mouth go
back there second time Kaka I mean you
might but this is the story of xqc we're
looking for the top players in the world
and the team owners who will form the
overwatch league a brand-new game and a
fully franchised geo-located league a
league that had the power to create
superstars overnight the overwatch
league changed the game we are working
towards launching the overwatch league
as the pinnacle of overwatch esports one
that all aspiring players and audiences
can celebrate strive towards and call
their own when the overwatch league was
first announced it instantly made waves
across competitive gaming those with the
first person shooter background flocked
to the game for a shot at a pro contract
everyone wanted in on the ground floor
one of those being Felix xqc long gel
no chatter oh excuse II was a tank main
and was building a reputation as an
incredible talent while piloting Winston
one of the game's premier space makers
he was aggressive yet controlled in game
something he wasn't outside of it like
many other up-and-coming players xqc
paired his competitive aspirations with
a rapidly growing as a broadcaster he
was completely uncaged the living
embodiment of the Internet a master of
memes games chugging cokes rage quitting
and of course that trademark flame for
xqc his journey began with a team called
dat's it which won a small Dreamhack
Montreal event and then q question mark
which was later acquired by denial
eSports hey guys my name is xqc I'm the
current tank for Team Canal and I play a
lot of competitive games so you might
know me from silky as well it was with
arc six that they qualified for season
zero of the overwatch League contenders
a proving ground for players who hope to
reach the big leagues in addition to
contenders many of the game's most
influential eyes were on the overwatch
World Cup in 2017 it's one of the
biggest cities in the world there's
gonna be a lot of eyes on you
opportunity this became an even more
pronounced proving ground for the first
season of the overwatch League and xqc
was the main tank for Team Canada
and execute see my just getting this
done himself there's nothing I can do it
can't get to the payload it's being
pushed away and that is gonna be that
second checkpoint I up here for Canada
all that whole pursuit oh it's a
beautiful Center for xqc to get the air
traffic the damage wasn't quite there
look at all the kills he managed to get
just with the use of that ultimate here
Australia rolled together one big juicy
package breakfast not traditionally
known as an eSports powerhouse Canada
impressed at the event and showed some
great synergy and teamwork that helped
them overcome some of the world's finest
it's chemistry this whatsoever or is it
time it is but where our Australia are
desperately it's a valiant attempt to
keep this game and I was not gonna be
enough Australia you're Crocodile Dundee
this is why Canada act here this is why
they're one of the best teams has an
all-star roster in the World Cup because
it's a new patch it's a new matter for
so many people but these guys pulled
this socks up and adjusted mid series to
bring the reverse swing that's true grit
the hallmark of a champion still is out
of the picture
in fact they made it all the way to the
finals where they eventually were
dispatched by a star-studded South
Korean team filled with many of the
overwatch league's future stars and xqc
was voted by the fans as the
tournament's MVP thank you so much one
who voted thank you so much
congratulations once again guys give it
up for XGC give it up for South Korea
[Applause]
when the World Cup came to a close and
it was time for the league's franchises
to start signing players for their
inaugural rosters XQ sees name was
prominent among prospective main tanks
[Music]
and on October 28th 2017 the Dallas Fuel
announced xqc as the ninth member of
their overwatch league season one roster
xqc is a spaz who can somehow keep this
life together but he absolutely
dominates his Winston in game one of the
best Winston's in the game like that's
not what a lot of people would say from
a guy not being playing professionally
for a long time it's like he's very very
driven to improve and I really admire
that about him when he actually gets
confident in himself and he's team I
think he's gonna do great things
he will stream all day we'll play all
day he doesn't care all he wants to do
is play and get good heading into the
league they were advertised as one of
the best especially when you looked at
the roster they managed to put together
with the likes of xqc on the tank line
the talent of players like tae Moo and
Mickey and the versatility of Siegel
they look to be one of the premier teams
to beat they have been the strongest
Western team throughout the whole of
2017 and 2016 this is a team with
pedigree and so much talent on the
roster but they stumbled out of the
gates down to zero whirring - Oh team
can Mickey get this ultimate up in time
yes he's going to get that self destruct
a pulse bomb itself to start to use
Mickey should get the mech back again
there is ot and so our last map will end
in a draw which means that Sol dynasty
as we said earlier has taken this series
this is just spinning out of
trol now for Dallas time ticking away
and that is it La Valle will take them
Bonnie and they will take the series
three and OH three wins in a tie will be
the result of this match between Devon
Dallas mule and the overwatch League
Houston outlaws or oh the Dallas mule
that's sweet and after the third match
against the Houston outlaws xqc made
matters worse for the organization when
he directed a homophobic slur at Austin
Mumma Wilmont an openly gay player in
the wise words of a good friend of mine
rolled and smoked my doggies no no he
didn't smoke shut your [ __ ] mouth go
back there second fan caucus I mean you
like but too many overwatch League fans
this was their first exposure to excuse
his toxic side but it certainly wasn't
his first time getting into trouble even
prior to joining Dallas he had his
account suspended by Blizzard for
abusing their in-game reporting system
on stream he was using it to spam report
the accounts of teammates that refused
to switch off characters he thought
weren't good enough for competitive play
I was genuinely [ __ ] up the game and
I get banned and 24 hours that's not
okay and while his online fame was just
starting to grow xqc style of digital
absurdity offered ample opportunity for
him to cross the line of what was
acceptable he fed off the energy of his
viewers and fans and humored them when
they urged him to tow that line the fuel
took matters into their own hands after
the league's announcement as well
extending his band from just four games
to the entire rest of the stage to
reinforce their stance on his actions
super sorry
two people that I vote down people that
support me that see me differently now
two members of the LGBT community I'm so
sorry
Mumbai myself even though I talked him
directly the outlaws as a whole my team
the fuel organization and watch League
entirely this could have been a huge
deal a huge disaster to the health of
the hood entirely tonight I am er send
them home and I'm sorry and when he
returned from his band he clearly had
something to prove
on stage push for the gladiators what a
combo from Dallas we'll see what happens
Thank You c-come in
he goes to the charge he says forget the
air shadow but no hairy hood gets Fisher
anyway they're not even gonna get the
Rhinehart ultimate out Costa going in
now with the coalescence they use the
sound barrier from Harry oak as well
hydration back in there's a graviton
surge
there's xqc with the double kill the
time is building one more time the last
attack for Dallas fuel it looks like it
may have done it her shad are coming in
the future can't capitalize
Dallas fuel will win case row I'm super
happy to be back after being like a
month off and in my room I'm super glad
pogcham in the chat and thanks for
everyone who supported us and thus began
the quintessential story of xqc the
constant back and forth between his
offstage antics and is increasingly
strong on stage performance what I love
about this as well is that he comes back
in and deals so much damage afterwards
we're into this gravitas ship generates
almost another one and then ports that
Deadeye that was coming out from sure
for the fantastic wake of another
provinces he returned to stage two with
a vengeance bolting himself into the
conversation among the leads best
maintains think that if he carries on
performing like this he could be a top
three top four tank in the league the
guy's got skills
I know that would make a lot of fans
happy home you guys wanna see more xqc
but the whispers of XQ sees Redemption
art were silenced just as quickly as
they started on March 9th 2018 xqc was
suspended by blizzard for the second
time in as many stages this time for
using the try harder mote in a racially
disparaging way towards one of the
overwatch league's casters I didn't I
didn't tap in to know much League and
look them who's on screen or whatever I
understand it could look like a but I
posted so very often I posted all the
time it's literally just how I greet
people
then I was just like dude Watson the
Dallas fuel took action and this time
there was no shot at redemption
NASA announced release of a few leaks
axial voice not even two full stages
into his overwatch career xqc one of the
league's most talented tank players and
popular personalities was removed from
the fuel entirely just as quickly as his
rise to fame happened his career looked
to be all but over
so for me like the illogic as a whole
was pretty bittersweet to say the least
when I got I was really [ __ ] happy
right
and I was like pogchamp and they're
almost happy for me dude and it was uh
it was nice but I just felt all
undeserving anyway at least for the time
being his time on the overwatch league
stage was over I decided it was because
I saw the two were elites since you will
be going home with annex released
Agnes's it was stay safe on the streets
my man this is it huge dramatic music
voice xqc immediately focused all of his
attention to his stream there watch this
come on Joe victim
as a broadcaster that now outcasts xqc
instantly flourished during his first
three months as a professional streamer
after being kicked off the fuel his
channel spiked up to almost 10,000
viewers concurrently and they were there
for exactly the same person that the
overwatch League had banned you see even
as a pro xqc never logged off he
famously which is chained his Dallas
fuel practices into paint 9 or 10 our
streams papa he is a gamer incarnate
strung out on red cans of coke in stick
you at ill ting match and bringing his
viewers along for the rage induced wide
especially better enough he was
streaming overwatch primarily his ascent
to the top 500 on ladder mixed with the
odd tracer game so he could show off his
GPS pocket but despite his high level of
play
this wasn't a competitive stream it was
meant to be entertainment games and
memes and screaming at the top of your
lungs and smashing your keyboards and
talking trash all compartmentalized into
one twitch URL packaged up nicely and
the volume cranked to a hundred and now
freed from the shackles of professional
obligations he let it all loose for
thousands to see
whether you loved him or you hated him
thought he was a talented tank player or
a toxic gamer he was still growing
later in 2018 he was signed to an
overwatch contenders team called goats
where he could continue to scratch his
competitive itch in the wake of his
departure from Dallas xqc was still
invited to participate in the 2018
overwatch World Cup to feel you know the
people in the crowd the energy the like
a bit of aspect it's a lot of fun so
[Applause]
I am looking for the ground doesn't one
get eaten drop the ground take that to
Vince they eat a bit more the wood xqc
range to your heart's content as Canada
makes the space they need what is the
but even though he knew he was walking
on thin ice he was unable to keep
himself out of trouble the 2018 World
Cup was not the Cinderella story Canada
and xqc had hoped for but China they
seemed to be right he will they need to
be tried to cook the points of the stuff
[Applause]
China would be in a gold medal match in
2019 XQ sees a streamer and broadcaster
first I think xqc is probably gonna be
one of your next big boys I think he's
awesome I think he's gonna do great and
I think he's really doing a good job
with picking the great games to play his
concurrent viewership numbers have
jumped to more than 15,000 at a time
most months and his popularity online
has surpassed the barriers of the
eSports community and started to blend
in with some of the most popular online
personalities he's a fixture with in the
uber popular subreddit our live stream
fails and he started to broaden the
scope of both his content and his social
circle excuses body looks like that
alien and in men in black you don't talk
about I find it excuse me he's now often
interacting with many of the other top
general interest streamers in sodapoppin
and Greek god X are we gonna at least
live near each other so we can hang out
with done shooting and then we'll get a
stream because we're bored well despite
the game still being a fixture on his
channel you'd be hard-pressed to still
call xqc an overwatch streamer quite
frankly it's difficult to call him any
one thing because his channel truly is a
living breathing entity he'll do play or
watch whatever's funny
whatever is dramatic or whatever people
are talking about online he's a variety
streamer top 500 overwatch player and
online tastemaker he's chasing one thing
and the only thing what he calls the
juice there's no clear definition of
what the juice is
if the juice is whatever you make it it
can be anything
nobody can define what it is for you you
know what the juice is right for me
like sometimes I think the juices when I
win a pop-up right I go oh money bag
whoo Maldon oh that's my juice
Oh
[Music]
juxtaposed within his gaming content is
what has come to be some of the most
popular content on his channel him just
sitting in front of a camera and
reacting to things don't a game don't I
gain we go game chat guys I think it's
time to go again he's added what he
calls the reddit recap every week where
he and his fanbase Traverse Reddit and
watch and react to all of the most
popular clips and highlights in the
online world Clint falls it for the bait
[Music]
did really did honestly
who would fall for this I entered in
something this is in addition to medium
Monday we're in what might be the most
terrifying content creation act of all
time he allows his chat to decide
absolutely everything on screen for the
entire stream
you'll do anything he'll IRL stream play
a hand simulator watch YouTube just chat
or literally sleep for nine hours
it's the ultimate chat experience
somehow someway there's a streamer who
will more or less do whatever they ask
of him at any time can you like it I'll
bow okay why would you mean like my
elbow but at what cost and that is truly
the question when it comes to xqc on one
hand we have this revolutionary
personality the kind of rambunctious
energy that's infectious enough to have
an entire subreddit Dischord channel and
community built around him simply acting
crazy online
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus tell me and on the other hand you
have someone who is been harmful to a
portion of the gaming site Geist someone
who's unafraid to cross lines uses slurs
like their commonplace and unabashedly
attacks teammates and competitors the GM
dude [ __ ] of the game [ __ ] off avoid
a piece of [ __ ] he's a living breathing
enigma a symbol of the rampant
unstoppable growth that is personality
based online content creation while
simultaneously attacking his own growth
by reinforcing the dark cloud of bigotry
that hangs over gaming in its darkest
hours recently he's moved back to LA
where he signed with the LA gladiators
contenders roster baby boys I just
joined the gladiators and the Sentinels
is this his path back to the pros he's a
real redemption arc in the future
his xqc good or bad for gaming a hero or
villain well that's for you to decide
but without question he's only going to
get bigger before we find out thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]